hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today I here with a money-making
guide so I know I haven't made a ton of
them in the past however I'm trying to
get back into them uh just as I find
money-making methods I'll post them for
you guys obviously that's what I've been
doing however I've been a little bit on
a Hiatus so we're going to come back
with a bang on this one so today we are
here with the best money-making method
in the game assuming it's not destroyed
by Bots this is a big ass dck because
sometimes a lot of bots can do this and
if JX hasn't banned a lot of accounts
then uh it can kind of be packed but
I've made a video on this in the past so
if you guys were around when I was at
around 300 Subs you're going to know
what this is however I didn't make it in
a money-making method form I made a
really fun video out of it at least I
thought it was fun it got a ton of hate
but I understand why and uh yeah it's
whatever I'm cool with it but uh so
today we are going to be doing the keter
gloves method so if you guys don't know
what that is let me go into the
requirements real quick because it does
require a lot of things so pretty much
it just requires you to have a pretty
Advanced account is what I'd say uh the
requirements are 44 room crafting 30
cooking 34 wood cutting 50 strength 53
Agility 50 thieving 52 mining 47 range
100 combat 50 Slayer on top of some
Quest main one is Legends quest so
pretty much you have to be able to do
gami gloves hard Diaries and that will
then give you the gam gloves three now
at this point if you do not know what
these things do basically the ALK price
and I'll kind of like look at my Onyx
bolts for an example example as you can
see right here you buy them in the GE
for $8.79 their High out price is a 9k
so their High out price is 9k that means
their low out price is 6k as the low out
price is you know 2third of what the
high high out price is so once you get
the low out price you multiply that
times 1.75 and that's what you were able
to sell it to this store for they pretty
much are just it's a better way of aling
stuff without actually having to Al so
for in the example of onyx you will make
10.5k so in this example oh you'll sell
them for 10.5 thus you'll be making
about 1.8k profit however you know at
with all stores in the game as you sell
more you have to hop so basically I'm
going to go there right now I meant to
show you guys the exact amount however I
I accidentally banked my cash so we're
just going to go ahead and price check
this as you can see we'll go by that 31
mil is what we're going to be starting
with and I'm going to tie myself see how
long it takes me to sell these things
and they we will go from there however I
guess at the beginning I'll kind of show
you guys where you need to go just
teleport to Tai boana and I don't know
if that's how you say it run up here
that'll be the shop as long as you have
your gloves on that's all you need and
you just go and sell things all right so
there's probably an optimal like setup
for this however with prices always
changing there's no way to actually know
exactly what it is I wouldn't imagine so
this is the setup I've gone for pretty
much every time I hop to a world I aim
to sell three staffs about five bolts
two of these and one of all these that's
pretty much my goal all right so right
now in the background you guys will be
seeing just a little bit of background
footage of me selling stuff to the shop
if you guys don't know how to do it I
would imagine it's pretty
self-explanatory but I just wanted to
throw it back there um a lot of the time
you'll go into Worlds where there
already be stuff sold so just adjust
what you're selling according to how
much stuff is in the shop this video at
least during these early Clips you guys
can see that there's a lot of stuff in
the store so then I end up like
realizing that and I kind of split this
video up into three parts basically the
loot that I get during a peak hour like
this was like five I think it was like
6:00 or so on I think a weekend so it
was it wasin peak time um then I split
it up into selling stuff into different
worlds in non- peak time and then I
split it up again into selling stuff
into the same world at a non- peak time
so the advantage of selling stuff to one
world is that you do not have to hop you
don't have to worry about anything you
just sit there every minute you sell off
one of everything in your inventory you
wait another minute and you do it again
it's very relaxing if you have an ALT it
is indeed one of the best things to do
with the game but yeah so that's how I
end up splitting up this video I just
wanted to kind of throw that out out
there for you guys so you guys had an
idea as far as to what direction this
video was going to go all right so I've
realized I've made a mistake as you can
see in this world right here there are
three people and that means I'm playing
during peak hours I'm going to try and
do this during non- peak hours to
further test this however if you think
that it's not that profitable during
peak hours I'm going to go ahead and
show you guys what I was able to make in
a span of just a little over 10 minutes
600k I yep that's that's legit 600k in
10 minutes which is 3.6 mil hour which
is insane all right here we go selling
off the last inventory that I'm going to
do for this little example this is
during non peak hours so I am making a
ton of money to be totally honest with
you guys I did not mean to sell five of
each of those that was definitely a bad
idea but uh yeah kind of messed up but
as you can see within 7 and a half
minutes I was able to make how much
money we went from 31.6 to 32.8 which
means we made 800k within the span of 7
minutes all right so as you can see
found a world all to myself I'm going to
go ahead and price check all of the
items that I currently have that is 32.4
mil so we are going to sit here and sell
off one of each item every minute it'll
countown so then I'll be able to sell
off another one and we'll see how much
money I'm able to make in a 10-minute
Span in my own world realistically this
is probably the most effective way for
everyone to make money but since more
like since everyone's realistically
focusing on themselves this will never
be the best way but it's definitely
something that's really really efficient
for all so let's go ahead I'll time it
for 10 minutes we'll see how much we can
make an hour just chilling in one world
and this would be the most efficient if
you were working on another account all
right so here we go we're going to
finish off the 10 minutes of selling
stuff to one world I didn't have anyone
come by so I had no interference with my
money-making per hour except the fact
that I accidentally sold 10 Earth battle
staffs which I'm a little disappointed
about which hurt my profit a little bit
but we started at
32.4 mil so we'll go ahead and price
check what we are at now so as you can
see we are at 32.7 63 which means we
made 3 and pretty much 50k XP in that 10
minutes which means in about an hour you
would be able to make a little
over how much money did I make so
that means you would be able to make
about 1.8 to 1.9 mil per hour this is
literally the equivalent of Zora and you
could do this on an ALT account however
it is necessary that you have the items
to do this I know that that is a huge
requirement but if you consider it if
you put a bond onto one or two accounts
to be able to make you buy these items
per hour like per four hours and you
bought them overnight it would
definitely be worth it I guarantee you
that all right so I hope you guys
enjoyed the video I'm just doing this
afterwards because I was really late at
night I made a terrible outro but this
is one of the best money-making methods
in the game that I know of um other than
that I mean it's definitely High
requirements but it is high reward like
it is insane so hope you guys enjoyed if
you guys did make sure to leave a like
if there's anything I can approve upon
tell me about it in the comments down
below make sure to hit the sub button
also check out the Twitter if you wish
it is in the description nonetheless
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
peace and now to embarrass one of my RS
friends everything is going to the no